[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
has been suspended from yet another
platform this time it's Instagram it is
again for targeting Jewish people in his
posts
um he was suspended late Sunday for 30
days and he took a screenshot of the
suspension notification from Instagram
and posted it to parlor which supposedly
he's buying and maybe he is or maybe
he's not
um he uh according to the post on parlor
what Kanye was trying to do is post a
screenshot of a text message exchange on
Instagram he said the text message
exchange was with Russell Simmons who's
the co-founder of the record label Def
Jam and
um Kanye is no longer affiliated with
death Jeff Jam as of last year and in
the screenshot supposedly Simmons we
don't know that it's Russell Simmons but
that's the claim encourages Kanye to
leave the fight and strategize and
rebuild your business and Kanye responds
with a disparaging Claim about Jewish
business people and says he was kicked
off for that
and it is just part of his obsession
with Jews at this point in time you know
the thing I'm really kind of struggling
in general with this thing Pat there's a
bunch of different things here first of
all
obviously as I said on the podcast today
I'm disgusted that so many people just
like agree with the stuff Kanye is
saying you know that unfortunately as
I've said before soft anti-Semitism
which is people believe this stuff just
as part of their day-to-day they just
don't go around posting about it but
like if you bring it up they go oh of
course Jews have conspired to control
banking yeah of course like they don't
they don't make it a part of their day
but with Kanye much like with Trump
they're feeling emboldened and more
comfortable and just saying that that's
what they believe that's one concern
second concern is that these 30-day bans
don't really do anything and they almost
just encourage and embolden the people
who say it's the Jews doing the Banning
that's number two and then number three
and then I'll let you weigh in because
I'm throwing a lot at you here number
three is
um the uh
uh blending of Kanye's only mentally ill
versus Kanye is genuinely anti-semitic
versus what is really appears to be the
truth which is he's mentally ill like
many people and he's also anti-semitic
and the anti-Semitism is coming out in
an uninhibited way because of the mental
illness well let me respond to the first
one at least just for starters please
because I think there is a debate about
whether this anti-Semitism was already
in the culture but because Kanye decided
to speak out about it it made it so that
other people felt liberated to join in
yeah that's one side then there's other
people who will say maybe there wasn't
this rampant anti-Semitism out there but
there are a lot of Kanye fans and so
when they hear Kanye say these things
all of a sudden they start researching
it in the worst of places and they
believe what he says says because they
like his music yeah it's probably a
blend of both of those things but you
see those people who are willing to go
on the overpasses of Highways and then
hold up their signs I feel like with
those people who are actively protesting
they probably have a history of this
sort of thing have always believed this
and now because it seems like it's
getting more mainstreamed in our culture
uh they're more empowered to say it so
it's super concerning because we know
where this road could head we have seen
this play out before and it's so one
thought on that I think that you're
right that there are two groups I don't
think the people who are hearing this
stuff from the first time from Kanye are
really researching it or deep Believers
of it I think for the folks that are in
the second camp that you described which
is the really big fans of Kanye and
they'll kind of believe whatever he says
I don't think I think they're very
casually going yeah I mean I guess you
know Jews do control banking I don't
know they're not deeply committed to The
Conspiracy Theory whereas the earlier
group that already believed this stuff
they are more deeply committed to it and
those are the people that like you say
that are on the 405 freeway bridge and
sadly with both of these groups I feel
like the fact that he was temporarily
banned from Twitter now he's facing this
band from Instagram yeah all of these
companies cutting ties with them it'll
just sort of reinforce the beliefs that
they already had and the things that
he's been espousing like they'll see
they'll say like oh it's clearly the
Jewish business owners who are trying to
cancel him and it just sort of backs up
whatever Kanye was saying yeah uh even
though this is just normal business
practice you don't want to associate
with someone who's going to say these
things and it has nothing to do with
ethnicity or religion but still they'll
use that to back up whatever claims that
they're making and that that's that's
really sad because that is effective
actually so that's this that's the
second point which it sounds like you
agree with now where are you on the
mental illness versus anti-Semitism
thing It's a combination of course right
because like there are plenty of
mentally ill people who are never going
to say this type of thing they don't
believe in this type of thing in the
first place maybe they're seeking
treatment maybe they're not but you
don't want to like combine those things
when they don't need to be combined
because you know clearly there's
distinctively different groups you could
also have someone who's anti-semitic
without being mentally ill I suppose
yeah
um and so it's just it's a combination
and we see these unhealthy combinations
take place in many different forms I
mean look at the Paul Pelosi attacker
maybe he was mentally ill combined with
uh being down these rabbit holes of
right wing talking points and in their
Echo chamber and everything else he went
that route so you can have these
dangerous combinations and with Kanye I
think it was mental illness plus the
anti-Semitism yeah the Pelosi attacker
also happened to be anti-semitic but
that's uh yeah par for the course at
this point all right so that's the
latest send us your thoughts if you have
thoughts on Kanye honestly I've never
liked Kanye nor his music and I've
always thought he was nuts and a bad
person so I would like to see him go
uh oh and one update to what we talked
about yesterday which was we were
unclear about the timeline for when
Kanye was brought back to Twitter it was
before Elon took over okay and
apparently the executives decided to
just take down that tweet themselves and
restore his account but they also
decided not to uh tell Elon that they
were going to do it so then when like
Elon tweeted about it it made it seem as
though Elon was the one who actually
brought it back but interesting well
that explains it that doesn't explain it
we've been covering this story of a high
school football coach who insisted on
praying on football fields for years at
this point in time and you might
remember that he ultimately lost his job
uh this ultimately led to a case that
made it all the way up to the Supreme
Court where he had a victory on
religious freedom grounds and now the
coach Joseph Kennedy is going to go back
to coaching football the position he has
not had since 2015. he will quote be
reinstated to his previous position as
assistant coach of Bremerton High
School's football team by March 15th of
next year according to the court filing
the U.S Supreme Court ruled in his favor
in June we covered the result at the
time and said the school district went
too far and pursuing its goal of
eliminating any perception that it was
endorsing religion the decision
overruled the lower court which had held
that the school was justified in telling
the coach stop playing with players on
the field now an NPR article says that
it is not totally case closed that there
is a joint stipulation here
and um the two sides are ordered to
create a way to bring the legal battle
to a close in the sense that I guess
it's not simply he can go back there and
just do the exact same thing necessarily
and there's a dispute as to the final
language of the injunction that is going
to be agreed to uh and it's sort of
going to have to be figured out but it
doesn't really relate to the prayer it's
that Kennedy apparently is going to have
to go through all of the hiring
forms and certifications again and there
is a question as to what attorney's fees
and reasonable costs he can claim since
he did ultimately Prevail which kind of
really bums me out that after all this
he's gonna have his legal fees paid for
I don't like any of this Pat you know
and and to be clear I respect the
decisions of Courts and yes this is a
very right-wing court and we've dealt
with that before we have no choice
I'm not advocating anybody go and do
anything violent or anything like that I
would like to see a different legal
framework apply to these situations yeah
I feel like this story is getting to the
point where it's more about the Saga
than the initial thing like this goes
back to 2015. he wasn't even a head
coach right he was an assistant coach
and all these lawyers got involved all
of these cases conservatives piling on
and trying to make this about religious
freedom broadly and an attack on the
liberals who don't want you to be
allowed to pray openly and all these
different things and then if you when
you hear about like the legal
representation the school district in
this case only had two lawyers versus
Kennedy who had five law firms backing
him up across several different states
so they were clearly outmatched the
school district was and maybe that's
part of the reason why he was able to
ultimately get the win here and having a
very conservative Supreme Court helps as
well yep I think it's obviously the
wrong ruling I hope it takes you know a
while for things to go back to normal as
they were over there and that he can't
just like start doing exactly what he
was doing before because to me that
seems very unconstitutional but just the
way things are going it seems like he'll
be back on the 50-yard line before you
know it yep I do it does seem that way
and
I mean I just I understand that in many
parts of the country prayer and high
school football are in that inextricably
linked and I get it I don't live under
some kind of you know Mis uh uh
understanding about all of that I would
just like to see it not be a part of the
of the sports that's that's all and I
know that lots of people just say no
David it should be a part we like it
yeah and we've made these points before
but the reason you should be against
this in my opinion is because it coerces
students to join with you in the prayer
if some student decides they don't want
to join in maybe they're not Christian
um you know maybe they're of another
religion or don't have a religion they
may feel as though they have to
participate anyway because they don't
they're going to be left out they may
not be able to start on the field for
the next week's game uh so that's why I
think it's coercive and that's why I
don't think it has a place and also just
this idea about praying when it comes to
football like if you're praying for
people's health and safety I guess that
makes sense right but if it's about your
team winning versus the other team that
doesn't make any sense no I completely
agree with you
um all right well I guess the next piece
of the story will be when he makes it
back onto the field and uh I guess we'll
let you know maybe
um as daylight saving time ends uh
uh and again I don't even is that
actually we isn't are we now going into
it no no no it starts in the spring it
ends in the fall right what we want is
permanent Daylight Saving Time right yes
okay daylight saving time is ending
meaning that on Saturday night into
Sunday
uh we gain an hour of sleep but we lose
the hour of sun starting on Sunday
afternoon and sunset will be much
earlier I don't like it for a long time
every year there's the debate should we
get rid of this should we get rid of
this it continues to be completely
unsettled the senate in March pass the
sunshine protection act which would just
enshrine a permanent daylight saving
time
it has stalled in the house and sleep
experts want a switch to Standard Time
so I don't know that we're really going
to make much of a uh progress on this
anytime soon and we hear all the same
arguments every year how does increased
Darkness affect energy consumption
because you need more lights on how does
the increased Darkness affect uh car
accidents because it's safer to drive in
daylight than an item how does it affect
farmers which is like an old thing that
that people talk about I wish we could
just make the change and move on from
this Pat but it really does not seem
like this is going to happen anytime
soon and the other issue I think that's
important to mention is
this is differently impactful in
different time zones like for example
Central Time Zone people apparently are
much better aligned during Standard Time
with a schedule Sun schedule that makes
sense then for example the East Coast so
different parts of the country have a
different view on this as well
to me it just points out how
dysfunctional our government is because
as you mentioned the sunshine protection
Act was passed back in March by the
Senate it was a unanimous vote so when
that happened I was thinking okay well
this is just a sure thing that's going
to happen right the house will also pass
it President Biden will sign this into
law clearly this is the type of thing
that people want sure there are
arguments on both sides but I think the
the car accident thing and the the
actual increase of medical calamities
that happen because of the clocks
changing and just the fact that people
want it lighter out later into the day
will make it so because the vast
majority of people want this I I would
imagine I haven't seen polling on it it
will mean that it will be able to pass
through the government and will have
this but then they just decided not to
take it up in the house they just didn't
have a vote on it and so it's stalled
ever since March and this is why we
can't have nice things we wouldn't have
to worry about switching back the clocks
this weekend if Congress could get their
act together but unfortunately we have
to deal with at least another year of
this and seeing the way things are going
many many more years possibly the
polling is Complicated by the fact that
I think a lot of people don't know
what's going on right and a lot of
people say they want to get rid of
daylight saving time yeah but what they
really mean is they want to make it
permanent more than a third of States
want year-round permanent daylight
saving time and have already passed
legislation saying we would do that if
the federal government decides to do it
as well but there's a lot of confusion
when you ask people do you want to keep
switching the clocks only 35 percent say
yes but then because of the confusion
about what it means to eliminate
Daylight Saving versus to make it
permanent I don't know that we can
really even trust the numbers on that we
should do a poll on how many people want
to change the name of daylight saving
time to Daylight Savings time that's a
good match how most people pronounce it
yeah that continues to be a an issue
there's another option too which is to
change your time zone like so if you're
in an Eastern State like New York for
example and instead of being on the
Eastern Time Zone you could advocate for
being in the Atlantic time zone but then
the problem is if you're the only state
to do it then you're very confused with
the other states around you and that
gets a little dicey as well well you
know Arizona and I believe it's a part
of Indiana although I'll be honest I
don't remember if it's true Arizona
doesn't do the time change so part of
the Year there are two hours behind the
east coast and part of the year they are
three hours behind the east coast and
they just kind of do their own thing and
you've got to remember sometimes we're
with California and sometimes we're not
and that's it apparently you get used to
it and another thing that this affects
is how people will regardless of the
time of year whether we're in daylight
saving time or not when they're um
trying to schedule something they'll say
like oh Eastern Standard time but half
the time you're actually in daylight
time but yeah people don't get that one
we just call it maybe we just make it
easy with our guests we say Eastern yeah
we do that but you could make it easier
for everyone people would altogether
stop making this mistake if we were just
in one time Zone all the time people
could make that change and we'll be done
with it absolutely Fair all right let us
know do you want and I'm going to assume
our audience understands what I mean do
you want permanent Daylight Saving Time
meaning the sun is out an hour later
during winter than it currently is when
we change the clock I hope that that's
clear let me know new show new bonus
show tomorrow